this is Startalk welcome to Startalk
your host Neil deGrasse Tyson your
personal astrophysicist and we are right
now recording this episode of star talk
from the Mashable world headquarters
right here in New York City and in this
latest installment of our new sort of
sub series of star talk called let's
make America smart again we have my
co-host today Chuck nice all right dude
you you you also host a spin-off of star
talk which I'm still getting into called
playing with science I know science
right there mama know you're playing
[Laughter]
yeah no it's a sports science mashup
show where we interview because we've
had sports YES on flagship start talking
you know it had whole followings unto
themselves that's right so we took that
spun it off and that was that mean you
not give me any sports athlete anymore
no no it just means that it means that
when we have athletes you'll come on the
show it was that and we also have
science and sports science in sport and
then for everything we also have
Startalk all-access comm where we have
exclusive original content like
something that you and I did which by
the way I'm gonna put a clip film but
and by the way the thing we did it's
called have you touched my meteorite you
don't remember that we were in your
office alright okay I'm gonna send you
the clip of this alligator I'm gonna
save it click but you got to put it on
Twitter if I send it to you it's me it's
wearing your office we're having a
conversation and so this is so funny in
the middle of the conversation you know
wait a minute
have you touched my meteor
I said that yes and I went no like would
you like to and I was like hell yeah
that's never had that sure I do stash a
couple meteorites um it was actually it
was very cool but nothing that everybody
ought to or should so for this edition
of let's make America smart again we're
gonna talk about the future of NASA and
so we brought in an expert on you know I
mouth off about NASA but very few
experts on this and we've got one with
us and you're the former chief scientist
at NASA that's right that sounds like a
badass business part - yeah chief by the
way I would just walk around all the
time - just yeah hi yes double latte
chief scientists at NASA
so you're Becca is a planetary geologist
that's correct
very cool and oh happy to be here this
and so we this is a cosmic queries
version of let's make America smart
again absolutely and so we're gonna take
questions with even pre solicited from
our fan base and social media typically
and these are questions about NASA and
weird scumming weird going and just to
be clear you're no longer the chief
scientist you've left that post that's
right I step down in December at the end
of the administration and so now I'm
trying to figure out what to do next man
whose name goes unmentioned right the
administration
what was your academic posts before NASA
before that I worked for a small group
of people at a company called proxy me
research and I did research on Venus I'm
a member of the Cassini radar to do
research on Earth about these Oh correct
I studied volcano winter I study
volcanoes on Venus Mars earth and one of
the moons of Saturn called Titan nice so
your volcano that is correct
welcome now how do you [ __ ] mind
they start your Vulcan mind it's almost
as good as chief scientist but not quite
so just to let the audience know there's
certain positions at NASA that are
appointed and that they rotate so that
you're not a career civil servant in
that post that's right the chief
technologists and the chief scientists
usually come in for two to three years
advise the NASA Administrator on policy
across the agency that's administrators
the highest-ranking mm-hm
the administrator is appointed by the
president and it doesn't sound nearly as
cool as two sides for sure what do you
do I'm the administrator of NASA and you
I'm the two scientists done with you
let's talk Harley Bolden is the coolest
person around so he could get away with
that we've had one start yeah it was
great great he deployed the Hubble
telescope so yeah that's right have you
been in space you've got stories so so
presumably you've thought about the past
present and future of NASA would you say
NASA is on track in all the ways NASA
wants to be on track NASA's on track
well let me say it another way
okay we all have ideas of what what NASA
should be doing is NASA doing it I think
so but there's always a caveat there
because because NASA is part of the
executive branch it gets its direction
from the president but then Congress
ultimately decides on NASA's budget and
so there's always this tension between
what does the president want
what does Congress want and does that
bear any resemblance towards what's
really important to NASA which is moving
humans out beyond Earth exploring this
planet exploring the solar system the
Sun the universe and not to mention one
other small thing this planet which is
the most important planet to all of us
so how are those resources being spent
how are they divided up and that's the
tension sometimes it's good tension but
it sounds like generally it's not well
no I think it is it is an
general a good tension because obviously
if you look back over the history of
NASA at the time of Apollo NASA was
about 4% of the federal budget right now
NASA is about 0.4% of the federal budget
and so that means you have to you have
to make choices
huit NASA still wants to invest in
aeronautics the commitment of the
country that's amazing yes you know and
so to someone like me I would say let's
go wild and make NASA 0.6 percent of the
federal budget and that would be a huge
amount of money 50% increase yeah a huge
amount of money for NASA but really not
that still that much of the federal
budget and to me that NASA is doing a
lot of amazing things and those things
actually benefit us every day I said
let's just go to a penny all right I'm
gonna raise it from point four wait just
go to 1% right you just want to take it
up to a penny
yeah and we're good yeah we're good to
go yeah we'd have humans on Mars very
quickly if that were the case and you'll
be doing the backstroke on Titan's
that's right that's right
finding life around the solar system
we'd be exploring planets around other
stars we'd be making huge advances and
and again for people who say oh that's a
waste of money those when you push for
technology you benefit our economy you
have spin-offs that affect our lives in
amazing ways so let me just we're just
America since we have so I think methane
is odorless you know you're right they
add that odor to it yeah so that you can
smell yeah so you the reason we thought
about is because because I dealt it
[Laughter]
you're you're contributing to global
warming so I think it's it's hydrogen
sulfide has that rotten egg smell
exactly mixed in with the methane right
but I would expect nothing you get by
always saying that you want to go do the
backstroke on the methane lakes of Titan
right
the smell no you're right and you know
it just doesn't work as a joke when I
say in the odorless methane gates with
the hydrogen sulfide Wow it's about 92
degrees Kelvin on Titan so it would be a
cold swim for you but but my real
question is is there anything else
swimming in those seas besides to it and
as we always do we start with our
patreon patrons questions because they
support us financially so it's a whole
like pay go to page on our website yes
that well you can and I would say there
was a little mysterious to me for a long
time great really because I thought is
this just another thing where they just
asking for money but you actually like
some kickbacks no the kickbacks at every
level absolutely actually by your access
you're buying access to the program just
like you know like for instance if you
were a Russian businessman and you
wanted to so yeah there's two ways to
support the show financially if you if
you're so inclined one is patreon and
the other is Startalk all-access comm
where we have little create all kinds of
exclusive original content plus
everything that we do and the money goes
back into what we do so that well what
it does is we use it to do innovative
things that can't otherwise be justified
by the business model at that time
absolutely and so we can grow whole new
branches and that's what is what we're
doing that's what we're doing it and
it's it's working and you just put it so
much better than I got to remember what
you just said there that's what it is so
anyway here's our patreon a question
from Chris Ryu Chris wants to know this
hey let's fast-forward a decade or even
a few and imagine a permanent Mars
colony assuming that NASA was
responsible what changes do you think
there would be to the role of NASA
globally would it perhaps take on a more
worldwide role would have become maybe
wasa and that's Chris from the atomic
Club or the atom Club in stru münster
Newton well first of all I think before
we actually have a colony on Mars it's
gonna be a little bit more than a decade
or two because those first journeys to
Mars with humans which will probably be
in the early 2030s for an orbital
mission hopefully down to the surface
soon after that - really after you mean
other missions yeah the mission that
first goes into orbit is not going to be
the one that way I don't think it'll be
the one that lands because that entry
descent landing on Mars with humans and
so is so hard because the Mars
atmosphere is is so thin so we're hoping
to get humans down on the surface by the
mid-to-late 2030s to really have people
there for sustained long periods of time
I think we're maybe three or four
decades away from that but but it's
already gonna be a world wide effort I
don't know if I want to call it wasa but
it you know already
NASA is actually working their 16 space
agencies that are working on this how do
we send humans beyond low Earth orbit of
different countries yeah so you know the
typical ones people have heard of may
the European Space Agency the Russian
Space Agency the Japanese Space Agency
but we've got space agencies from South
Korea emerging space agencies from
Africa who are participating India um so
it already is a global offer not only
that I don't think it's just gonna be a
government I've heard it's gonna be
public-private partnerships and we
already see things like SpaceX with red
dragon sort of moving forward though
it's not clear what's the exact timeline
on red dragon is right now but I think
it's gonna take kind of everybody
participating to actually make it happen
so are you saying that that first colony
will not be NASA and American tax monies
it'll be a collaboration the way this
questioner is asking I think it will be
a collaboration but I think there will
be I hope America continues to lead
we've always led but that doesn't mean
we can't have partners and so I hope we
continue to lead I hope there is a US
base on Mars eventually and I think a
lot of people do envision it's sort of
like Antarctica where there's a US base
a British base but I'm actually hoping
we all
together internationally like we do up
on the International Space Station
that's sort of the partners I know I'm
obviously that's very wishful thinking
they're also I would have I want to
differ with something you just said you
said we've always led but I think we
only really led after maybe 1968 oh good
point yeah the space that's why they're
the first satellite they had the first
non-human animal they had the first
Leica yeah like a that the first human
they had the first woman they had the
first black person a Cuban they had the
first Space Station
they had so worse landings on Venus the
first planes they actually had the first
photo of Earth rise on the moon which
wasn't released till after our photo was
was so so we were reactive to so much of
what Russia did leaving me to wonder
that if Russia never went there whether
we would have ever had a space program
in the first place I I think we may have
eventually but it would have come much
slower and so there's an interesting
parallel going on with that right now as
you see the rise of the Chinese space
program lot going on in China right now
they're getting ready to put their
education to use if that's what it takes
to Mars which gives back reflects back
to your first question about is NASA on
the right track we're on the right track
to get humans to Mars that whole plan I
talked about but it could easily go off
the rails and and so in my mind maybe it
takes a little incentive by competing
with foreign nations to keep us on track
I like the Train reference with
referencing rockets it might go off the
rails by the way if we do get a train
tomorrow what else you get all right
here we go
hey along the same line this is boone
arcane from facebook says do you think
NASA will lose some significant funding
in the near
future since we're talking about all
these grandiose plans especially with
competition and if so what will NASA
what research will be halted first and I
would like to add to that what are we
doing in terms of public-private
partnerships because if we're losing
funding are we are we supplementing that
in some way or is it when we pull from
in a way that's the end of it
programs are shut down yeah NASA hasn't
been losing funding actually over the
last several years our budget has gone
up over the President's request and up
it's barely keeping pace with inflation
but it is going up when other lots of
other parts of the federal budget are
going down and that's because NASA still
continues to have huge bipartisan
support in Congress so because it has
ten centers half of which are in blue
states the other half are in red state
so it continues to have a lot of support
what again though the subtleties are for
example I testified in February before a
congressional hearing on the on the
future of NASA and there was a lot of
talk by some members about do we need to
refocus NASA's budget do we need to
focus NASA on what it should be doing
that's a bit of code for why is NASA
doing earth science and that's when I
start to get worried so it's not only
the absolute number it's how is that
money spread around and to me NASA's
earth science budget is an extremely
important part if we don't measure
what's going on on this planet we're not
going to understand it because after all
it's a planet it is a planet yeah one
more before we go to break okay all
right okay let's make this very let's
make this interesting
Chad Thompson would like to know this
could NASA be the precursor to something
like the Star Trek Federation mmm which
is really kind of cool I mean now it's
you spoke that kind of briefly but is
there a concerted effort to bring these
agencies together globally there is
there's again there's something called
the global exploration roadmap you can
google it all these space agencies the
heads of all the international space
agencies get together
several times a year and meet and say
what are we doing how can we work
together how can we you know everybody's
got limited resources so it's better to
work together and so you know if you
look at the Space Station people have
suggested it would should be nominated
for a Peace Prize you know it's
literally higher ground where we can get
along and to me if we can keep space in
that realm the better off we're gonna be
a Space Station is the greatest
collaboration of Nations outside of the
waging of war oh look at the budget god
that is so just there's a nice couraging
it's just in fact I mean it's it's it's
heartening in one respect that we can
get together and do other so there's the
Olympics there's the World Cup okay and
there's a Space Station if you look at
the budget that drives these the Space
Station is a greater budget and greater
sort of total investment and the only
other time nations get together like
that is to kill one another
yeah oh we are awful do you know that
human beings you suck this is this this
is why we should fear AI because when
achieve consciousness it'll be cleared
or did that we just have no right to be
alive at all there you go it'll be its
first task let me tell you something I
have no intelligence at all and I still
agree with that we're done with this
segment when we come back more of our
cosmic queries edition of let's make
America smart again see you in a moment
we're back Startalk we're talking about
the future of NASA in this edition of
let's make America smart again
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson I've
got my co-host chuck nice hey we didn't
hit Chuck nice comic thank you sir yes
right and I've got with us since we're
talking about the future of NASA we got
somebody who would just been working for
NASA for the last several years in the
capacity of chief scientist I've got
Ellen stofan here Owen hey nineteen-year
not your first time on Startalk not my
first time but always happy to be here
excellent excellent we love this and so
Chuck you've been soliciting queries yes
I have all over the Internet
about the future of NASA so let's see
and in this again the mid our goal here
is to imagine a smarter America going
forward so let's see what do you have
here
alright so Anna hi Suze coming to us
from Facebook would like to know this
what is the main difference between NASA
and SpaceX in terms of what they would
like to achieve in space exploration in
the near and far future and let me add
to that what is the chief purpose of
NASA or what is NASA's mission statement
well I should be able to quote National
NASA's mission statement from memory but
I but I can't but it's basically to
understand our world our solar system
our universe and to use technology to
move humans beyond Earth that that is
really if you want to sum it up
that's NASA's mission exploration
knowledge so SpaceX is a contractor to
NASA NASA has lots of industry partners
SpaceX is one of them they launch cargo
up to the International Space Station
starting next year they'll launch crew
up to the International Space Station
from Florida so they're one of many
contractors now obviously SpaceX is off
obviously stated that they want to see
humans on Mars NASA wants to see humans
on Mars so our goals are actually really
aligned and we have a partnership with
SpaceX to help them land one of their
dragon capsules on Mars and I'm excited
because they've done a lot of work on
entry descent and landing that'll
hopefully make it able for us to land
humans sooner you said earlier that one
of the challenges is that Mars has a
thin atmosphere could you detail why
that's more of a challenge to all right
miss fear is much denser so if people
haven't seen there's a great video that
JPL put together before the Curiosity
rover the before the Curiosity rover
landed called seven minutes of Terror
and it basically takes seven minutes
when you're coming in from a trajectory
from Earth to get from the top of the
atmosphere to the surface so you have to
slow yourself way way way way down
you've got good speed to get there you
know you got to eat up that speed
somehow yeah
and and to absorb that speed coming the
atmosphere is just not helping you very
much but it's heating you up which is
bad so you've got to find some way to
slow yourself down so curiosity weighed
one metric ton and we used a combination
of earth unless so that's the mass what
did it massive of a thousand kilograms
yes so we used heat shield parachutes
this bizarre thing called a sky crane to
land it on the surface we estimate for
humans you're gonna need 20 to 40 metric
tons landed on the surface and the more
you can bunch that into single landings
the cheaper it is so there's there's
issues with that so how are you gonna
slow yourself coming down you're gonna
have to use something called supersonic
retropropulsion which basically hurts
because you're firing retrorockets while
you're going at supersonic speeds which
causes all kinds of turbulence
everything you're shooting up the back
comes back at your spacecraft at
supersonic speeds so it's a crazy thing
SpaceX has actually been working on it
well I try so so if you're moving
supersonically and you try to put retro
exhaust in front of you you overtake
these right exactly yeah so it's
complicated to say the least so it's not
that it's an insurmountable oh my gosh
we can't ever send humans to Mars it's
too hard and it frustrates me sometimes
I'll see commentary of saying oh we just
need to stick at the moon Mars is too
hard Mars is not too hard we can figure
it out yeah just any engineer with froth
is amount to have the opportunity
problems exactly and again when you
solve tough problems like that you're
you're stretching technology yours
stretching computational skills you're
patenting your patents oh you're you're
spinning off stuff into our economy
right here on earth let me know all
right here we go this is Jeff saw stress
and Jeff says Chuck you have butchered
my name I'd like to clear the record
it's sauce like spaghetti interests like
the syndrome
sauce Tourette's thank you thank you
Jeff
phonetically clarifying your name here's
what he wants to know what is the
average age and education of a NASA
employee is the demographic getting
younger or older over the years
so are we attracting people to NASA by
the way we all saw the video of the
launch and return of the first stage in
the SpaceX rocket and you see Mission
Control for SpaceX there's nobody there
over 30 there's one old fart who's 40 in
the corner looking around like this
everybody else who's jumping and
hollering
if this 35 I'm so that skews young it
looks to me it does Q young and if you
look at our NASA centers which again we
have nine NASA centers plus our
federally funded research and
development center the Jet Propulsion
Laboratory makes ten but I need to know
more about the FFRDC see the average age
is about 52 to 56 depending on the
center now part of that is because we
have people who who don't want to leave
you know they love what they do they're
still productive we've had scientists
who are still you know writing
significant papers in their 80s so that
does tend to hurt your your statistics
on the other hand you know I was in the
60s everyone just died at age 60 well
it's kind of we have people who don't
like to retire
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
the spam was food you're eating emails
that you don't want what we've also had
periods of time where the federal
government has hiring freezes on and so
and and NASA downsized when the shuttle
program ended so all of that's combined
to make the federal our federal work
force older and we need more younger
people in there when you have a hiring
freeze but it applies to NASA it's a
brain freeze it applies to NASA it's a
brain freeze cuz you're not you're not
bringing in fresh fresh brain blood
right which means that those those those
resources are being allocated someplace
else
most likely Wall Street right and and
the other thing is though you really
want that mix of Ages because you know
we've got people who really know how to
land on Mars you know we have people who
know how to keep humans up in space safe
so you need that kind of wisdom and you
need the fresh blood coming in that's
gonna carry that foreign culture with
fresh blood who is not biased by how you
always did do it can be open to a new
idea exactly and that that need for
innovation is something that we worked
on a lot over the last couple years at
NASA how do we ensure that we're the
most innovative it's a 50-50 year plus a
old agency you really do worry about are
you being the most innovative and NASA
worries about that interesting I know
the age of NASA because it was founded
the same week I was more 1958
[Laughter]
Brad Carrico from Facebook would like to
know this does NASA have a future
solution to the growing space junk
problem so are you guys working on this
NASA's working on space junk come from
space junk is because over the last 50
plus years we put a lot of stuff up
there some of it has broken up so there
are actually even like old stages of
rockets pieces of spacecraft there's
been and there was an occasion a couple
years ago where two spacecraft ran into
each other and it created a whole lot
more pieces of debris so there's just a
lot of stuff up there now it's slowly
slowly D orbits but we do worry about it
a couple times a year they have to move
the International Space Station slightly
to avoid space junk other satellites we
have to watch when we launch things to
say is there anything else on the path
now space is big so this isn't anything
to panic over but space agencies around
the world and private companies are
looking at how do we literally vacuum
that stuff up and people of I've seen
proposal the space station is not a
particularly nimble thing it's not even
sort of structurally I mean like the
solar panel like if you push over here
this will like bend but you're not gonna
push the whole I mean so you're telling
me they do avoidance maneuvers with the
International Space Station so they
don't run into somebody's shoe or
whatever a piece of debris was a lift in
space they do and they've even had rare
occasions where they realized there was
debris approaching the space station and
they haven't had time because obviously
to do a maneuver you have to say you
have to plan this out this isn't
something you want to be like oh yeah
let's move you know there's nothing any
in Falcon right
No so there have been times where the
astronauts have actually retreated into
the Soyuz capsule and waited out a
potential debris encounter don't you
love the way that's phrased a potential
debris encounter with something crashes
NASA for death but it's avoided I mean
the space station if you looked at it
closely it's got little pings and pock
marks all over it from little tiny
pieces of debris hitting it at 17,000
miles an hour and so that creates little
problems but so far 17,000 mile an hour
debris but that's why it's getting old
and at some point we will have to do
your but the space station right now
it's funded through about 24 by about 28
this for example the 2024 2024 so by
about 2028 a lot of the systems will be
degrading especially the solar panels
which are getting pinged by this micro
debris all the time so when we do orbit
that does that who puts a new one up
there
when do we do that you know that's a
great question and so there's this big
what is gonna happen to low-earth orbit
right after the space station is it
going you know if you talk to NASA they
would like it to be the commercial the
private sector that moves in private
space stations a place for you know
private company space companies Blue
Origin SpaceX orbble ATK let's find the
private sector going going to low-earth
orbit as imagined in the film 2001 all
there was Howard Johnson's up there Pan
Am ran the shuttle Pan Am for those of
the younger of our audience right a
former airline company it's the it's the
Virgin America before America was a
virgin if you really if you really get
underneath that NASA spends about three
billion dollars a year on the
International Space Station and if we
want to send humans to Mars we want to
take that three billion dollars and
start start building what will be the
Mars transfer vehicle what humans will
go in on that journey to Mars
if they have to keep spending it on the
space station there's not gonna be no
money to go to go beyond low-earth orbit
can we just have another three billion
dollars yeah
that's all that would be a great
solution wouldn't it then we wouldn't
have to worry about this but as it is
there's not enough money to do both
right now there is not so NASA's budget
plans for moving humans to Mars count on
the space station budget declining
through the mid-2020s and zeroing out in
the late 20s so now because and okay I'm
sorry I have to ask this since you were
there and this all sounds highly
political to me because you're talking
about budgetary issues but isn't there a
way to take the billions of dollars that
are going into Lockheed Martin's making
a fighter jet that we do not need or
tanks that we are building that the
government that the I'm sorry the
military has said we do not want them
but yet because it's a jobs program we
have to make them anyway
couldn't we just find a way to shift
this money over to NASA so that I mean
it there there's clearly inherent
benefits and discovery and technological
advances that will be wrought from going
to Mars as opposed to a tank that we're
never going to use because we're never
gonna fight conventional warfare again
we now have nuclear wars anybody we're
gonna fight it's gonna have a nuclear
warhead too
so we're not gonna do that so why can't
we just find a way to politically get
the senator or the congressman to say
hey look we'll give you the money you
just got to build whatever you're gonna
build over in my district Chuck nice
twenty twenty make America appreciate
science more again I can't remember
you're very smart
there we go there we go
well you know NASA can't lobby Congress
that's not actually allowed so outside
supporters can talk to NASA I am
flabbergasted yes I can't even advertise
yeah guys it killing me are you kidding
- just to be clear what the military
does when they have TV commercials
during the Superbowl is not ever that's
not technically marketing their week no
no yeah they're recruiting yeah oh so
what happened was when I was on one of
my commissions we were approached by an
ad agency that wanted to create sort of
public service spots for NASA to
recruitment through scientists and
engineers in the spirit of the Army Navy
Air Force Marines recruiting and that
way you can justify commercial time for
it and there's some of the most
beautiful commercial I've ever seen it
was just the the tradition to do that is
just not there yeah
that is so sad it's it's it's almost as
if our government has stacked the debt
against what we should be doing about it
but it that it sounds good the way it is
but imagine that in a limit where it's
out of control
because all it says is we taxpayers
elect officials who then establish
budgets for agencies the agency can't
then market itself for more much to ask
for more budget okay Wheatly external
activity from it right so that's that's
one set and why won't feel good that
NASA should be able to do it in the
limit you don't really want that
happening okay yeah I don't want I don't
want a Greek altar department doing the
same thing so we had a quick break when
we come back more cosmic queries in the
let's make America smart again edition
of Startalk we'll be back with Ellen
stofan former chief scientist at NASA
not that a lowly science it would talk
about when we return welcome back to
star talk
I'm your host Neil deGrasse Tyson I
serve as the director of the Hayden
Planetarium at the American Museum of
Natural History
right here in New York City if you
didn't otherwise know that in any case
I'm your personal astrophysicist we've
been talking with Ellen stofan for
a chief scientist of NASA very just
former yes formally minutes ago
practically six months minutes between
the in a cosmic scale it's yesterday and
I got Chuck nice of course doing cosmic
queries yes so we're thinking about the
future of NASA in this let's make
America smart again edition yes we have
star talk so what you have all right so
this is al okay I think these people are
making these names about and to send
them in to screw me man all right not
everybody can be named anyway who will
get to Mars first who will get a human
to Mars first that's that's all the one
is because clearly here's a real
question has it become like a space race
have we started the space race again no
I don't think we have and you know again
I think people like to have a rhetoric
around there being a space race but but
I don't think there is
so for Mars again Mars is hard it's not
easy it's not impossible but it's hard
so I think when we get humans to Mars
you're gonna see it you're gonna have
people from multiple space agencies
you're gonna have public-private
partnerships involved now you could turn
that question around for the moon and
that I think is a valid question because
there's a lot of talk about human bases
on the moon commercial exploitation of
the moon and whether that happens or not
boy I'm curious about that is is it
going to be China putting humans on the
moon is it going to be Russia finally
putting humans on the moon is it going
to be a private company and I'm leaning
towards a private company doing it and
so there I think that's a debatable
question Mars it's gonna be an
international coalition with hopefully
not NASA taking the lead
so does it help to because everybody
talks about a moon base
does it help us get to Mars is it easier
for us to get to Mars from the moon than
it is for us to get to Mars from here so
in other words who could could the moon
be a staging place to launch to go to
Mars it's a great staging place because
if you think about it you're gonna need
a multiple module vehicle to get to Mars
because you want to always have multiple
modules in case something goes wrong
with one of the modules you can seal it
off and still have a safe place to
retreat to so it's going to be something
big that you're gonna have to assemble
on orbit why not do that out in orbit
around the moon where you can use a Mars
gravity or sorry a lunar gravity assist
to get you ready to go to Mars
so staging from lunar orbit makes sense
from a gravitational assist point of
view as well as just you're gonna have
to stage somewhere why not why not do it
there just to be clear you're not
talking from the lunar surface which
requires landing in the ascending yes
Stane staging from the lunar surface
really doesn't make any sense because
it's different technology to land on the
moon moon doesn't have an atmosphere so
it's you'd have to develop all these
technologies specifically to land on the
moon because frankly all those things we
developed for Apollo are basically gone
at this point we'd have to sort of start
all over again
so that's a whole lot of money so so I
agree with you but for different reasons
I think we need to remind ourselves what
it is to leave low-earth orbit and the
moon becomes a very easy target that you
can get to in a news cycle right this is
just a few days how are you doing good
you don't get bored with the trip
everywhere there how you doing you land
in four days you come back for dinner
Sunday night and so this I think we have
to remind ourselves what that's like
yeah and without that do you just say we
haven't been I would have low Earth
orbit in 40 years not let's go to Mars
that doesn't sound wise to me as well
it's not wise and and it also takes us
out into what we call a mixed field
radiation environment where we really
don't have a lot of experience you're
getting solar radiation from the Sun and
you're getting galactic cosmic ray
and normally shielded when we stay near
to the earth exactly exactly so to have
a couple years out in that mixed field
radiation environment where we can do
some experiments with tissues with cells
with model organisms like fruit flies to
make sure let's make sure we really
understand the effects before we send
humans all the way to Mars
eight months exposed to that radiation
on the way there eight months on the way
back right yeah that reminds me were
joke by Dick Gregory that he told back
in the 60s on the point of what effect
does this radiation have on a biological
tissue right he said when the chimp came
back from space right everyone was
cheering right and they said no I wasn't
cheering because I know that that was an
actual astronaut you know when we first
something-something to space we had no
idea what the effects would be after all
this experience on the space station we
now know and we've worked on the ISS you
know people say what are those
astronauts doing up there they're
actually helping us find ways to keep
humans healthy on for that journey to
Mars the journey back to Mars but the
one thing we still have a lot of worries
about is this radiation issue and it's
not it's not something we can't we can't
work with but we still need to know more
about it right yeah and so the people
say oh we will never go to Mars because
the radiation all I'm gonna say is Mars
is not as big of a challenge to us today
as the moon was in 1969
Wow think about that yeah that's true
because we went to the moon basically
with the computing power of a Texas
Instrument calculus than that really
which for realistic is like like the
singing greeting card or something
you're kidding
someone was saying the other day I had
just flipped me out that the Voyager
spacecraft has about as much computer
smarts as something in your pocket your
car key because everyone instantly
thinks yourself you're kidding me the
key fob on your car
oh my god oh man that's now that is
fascinating that is mind-blowing right
there all right
here's um John Kate's from Facebook
thank you John for having a simple man
John oh this doesn't have any space
capable drones these would be drone
rockets I guess all drones we know of
require air for buoyancy right and all
our spacecraft are robotically
controlled drones what we do is
robotically remotely control so pretty
much all of NASA
is space capable drones so drone is the
is everyone else's first encounter with
a remote-controlled now what he may be
asking about and I'm gonna make his
question into maybe not the question he
wanted was the Jet Propulsion Laboratory
is working on a helicopter for Mars that
you can think of as being like a drone
that would would fly here on earth and a
group from the Applied Physics lab has
has proposed to one of the NASA mission
programs to send a basically a
quadcopter to Titan Saturn's moon so
people have been proposing to use drone
like you know what we would think of for
drones here on Earth's atmospheres to go
explore planets without yeah but if you
but if you said a remote control
helicopter to Mars first it would need
really big rotor blades because the
atmosphere is so thin but now you want
to remote control it you got issues
whether the issues the big issues
there's about a 20 it depends on how far
away Earth and Mars are but you have an
environment relative to each other but
we have an inherent up to kind of 20
minute to a half hour one-way trip time
for a command so you send the command
yeah it's just nothing can be done about
it I have audiences all the time saying
can you fix that oh no and then they'll
say no really can't you fix that right
no it's called the speed of light no I
exactly can't fix that so you have to
have basically computer program
sequences to command it there's no real
time Jois ticking and this is where AI
comes into play because you would have
to equip the drone with the capability
of recognizing terrain and situations
and then be capable of making decisions
on its own exactly I guess to Mars and
you say do you need my help
no we got this think of it for humans
because now all of a sudden houston we
have a problem and you're gonna wait 20
minutes and you'll hear back what you
know can you clarify there's no there's
none of that so you really do need AI
you need really how it's right yeah so
yeah 20 minutes there 20 threads of 45
minutes so basically a is Houston we had
a problem but it's all taken care
yeah we saw exactly exactly and just
think of that though on the other side
for human mental health you haven't seen
your family in 7 months and you call
your spouse and you say honey how are
you doing and 20 20 minutes later you
hear our sorry 40 minutes later you hear
what there's no witty repartee and there
is nothing right and like you say that's
the speed of light so there there is no
subspace communicate that's why people
ask you can you fix it they're all Star
Trek fans like myself and they want to
know how do I get subspace
communications where I can talk to
somebody in real time right across the
galaxy there's no episode of Star Trek
where there's a time delay okay always
good time from where like one more
question okay all right all right all
right with all the buzz about Mars
because we've been talking about it
Europa and Enceladus doesn't ask to have
any interest and looking towards the
inner planets like Mercury or Venus and
I know you used to study beep oh man
yeah dr. funke's boon and I are
our old one of our our star Clark
all-stars so Venus is the earth gone bad
a lot of times we refer to it as the
Earth's evil twin nice so made of about
the same material would you I just fell
in love with Venus so the problem is
here you've got this planet that again
started out in about the same place in
the solar system made of the same stuff
it's like you put two chocolate cake
mixes in the oven and one came out
chocolate and one came out lemon in the
end now this is important because you
could say well who cares that Venus went
down this alternate path where it's 900
Gries fahrenheit on the surface there's
a runaway greenhouse well we're starting
you know in the last couple years we
found over 3,000 planets around other
stars with our Kepler space telescope
and what we're looking for is earth 2.0
this habitable planet around another
star so this makes us even more curious
about Venus you had kind of multiple
chances in our solar system at habitable
planets only the earth was able to
maintain long-term habitability Venus
might have had an early ocean losted
although it's co2 is in its atmosphere
it has a runaway greenhouse why how hard
is it to make earth 2.0 Venus can help
us figure that out and that's pretty
damn cool I gotta say penis is grateful
it's the ignored planet of our solar
system not love me some Venus it's
beautiful in the evening and morning sky
it is Jason Nichols mom wants to know
this what NASA project that is cancelled
that you wish would be revived my Titan
boat proposal I proposed to send a
floating probe to a sea at the North
Pole of one of Saturn's moons to find
out is there anything living in that
alien sea someday it will fly this is an
ocean of liquid methane exactly methane
the gas that comes out of the household
stove okay and if you say so
comes out goes though in the suburbs it
might be propane but typically the
cities it's methane the simplest of the
hydrocarbons if I remember correctly CS
ch4 and it's got an H in for direct as
it's a beautiful molecule actually turns
the magazine so but it's normally it's
gaseous in our lives but if you drop the
temperature you liquefy it yeah yeah and
so so it's basically seas of liquid
gasoline and totally exotic very cold we
don't know if there could be life it
wouldn't probably be life like life here
on earth as maybe life doesn't require
liquid water maybe just requires it the
same way yeah and tightens the place to
go to answer that question
so wait but it got cancelled so it
didn't get selected we were one of the
final three missions for a discovery
selection and they instead picked a
mission to Mars called the insight which
will launch next year we planned a
seismometer on the surface so it's it's
it's still out I mean the idea is still
floating the ideas the ideas still
floating the problem is complicated but
it's basically dark a Titans poles
during Titan winter and the see the big
C's are all at the North Pole it'll be
dark at the North Pole from about the
mid 2020s to the early 2030s so there's
no point in going inland so you lost
your window we lost our way okay yeah
I'll be too old but you know it'll be
there why sorry well no it was your
dream when it happens and if we continue
to train the next generation of people
to become scientists and engineers or as
a minimum to embrace what scientists and
engineers do then this is a recipe to
assure
that America will become smart once
again yes well let's let's please hope
hope hope is what you have when you've
confessed we have no impact on the
outcome what well that's very
okay right hope and prayer that's what
you do when you're not in control
exactly okay so I'm saying let's get in
control then no you don't have to hope
you don't have to pray and when you look
at all the people who've been shot out
of stem for so long and that if we now
can get those kids involved in stem
we're gonna have a much larger more
innovative more creative stem workforce
than we've ever you've been watching and
possibly only listening to Startalk
let's make America smart again edition
with cosmic queries and I've had Ellen
stofan
Thank You Ellen multiple times on
Startalk and always great to have you
get your insider insights into the past
present and future of NASA chuck amen
always good to have you as my co-host
course i i've been and will continue to
be your personal astrophysicist Neil
deGrasse Tyson until next time I bid you
to keep looking up